at Kitt Peak Observatory in Arizona
solar astronomer Matt Penn studies this
solar surface to discover how photons of
light get trapped there's a bunch of
serious today but we will get some data
using the McNab pierced telescope he
focuses the sun's light to scan the
photosphere in detail so what we've got
are a few small sunspots on the disk of
the Sun we've got two sunspots two large
ones they're heading off to the edge of
the Sun to the limb of the Sun but
they're all accompanied by smaller
sunspots groups of smaller ones
following them sunspots mark areas where
light is trapped so a sunspot forms a
dark spot by removing energy from that
part of the Sun it's blocking the
convective flows that transport the heat
and the light from inside the Sun to
space and so we see then as a cooler
region that appears dark to us a
powerful force stops our photon dead in
its tracks preventing its light and
energy from leaving the sun's surface
that force is magnetism
sunspots take shape where intense
magnetism from deep inside the Sun
blasts up through the photosphere
the magnetic fields are so strong that
it actually stops the convective motion
of hot inner material from flowing to
the surface so you actually get what
looks like a cool spot on the surface of
the Sun they can be huge
the largest over ten times the size of
Earth
you